this is spare key for honda civic 2016
this is the customer's working key this
is the new one so i'm gonna put the new
key in and turn the ignition on
i'm using autel
so go immo
accept
honda
automatic selection
yes
[Music]
so the time there is 308
beautiful man
[Music]
the
central lock-in should go in
automatically with these as well
[Music]
park anywhere likes
there we go so
let's take a scan
[Music]
so add key
so the register keys are already
programmed key which is
[Music]
turn the ignition off
turn the edition on using a registered
key
so it's back on
[Music]
yes we would
turn ignition off within 15 seconds
insert the new key so i'll take that one
out
get the new one
put it in
[Music]
and turn it on
within 20 seconds
i'd like to learn the next one
turn the ignition off
so we have
on using the same key
[Music]
turn the ignition off
turn the ignition on
[Music]
yes it does there's no
immobilizer indicator lamp
turn the ignition off
turn the ignition on
[Music]
so the key number's now gone up to three
so we'll escape
we'll exit that
[Music]
this should now work
so that's our new key
this is the customer's original key
[Music]
we'll just make sure our starts as well
put it in
the car kicks up ground as well
so that's a spare key on a honda civic
in under five minutes thank you
[Music]
you